>> Mike: HE WENT 16 NDLED THERE
RANNTA.
HE HAD GRZELCYK WITH
CHARLIE COYLE.
WILL USE THAT B
FEND OFF PESCE. WIDE.
HALL.
GOALTENDER.
THE BRUINS GETTING SOME CHANCES
AFTER ALL HOPE GETSTS BY SLAVIN
AS FOLIGNO WAS NINO
NIEDERREITER.
ERIC HAULA STAYS ON HIS SKATES
THERE.
THE
THEY CONTROL THE PUCK.
THEY CONTROL THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE.
WHAT A PASS RIGHT HERE.
ERUPTING PNC ARENA.
>> APPED OUT.
DOMI WITH A QUICK  WHEN YOUR PE
COMES OFF, YOU MUST IMMEDIAT
IT IS DeANGELO.
TRY TO GET IT THROUGH, THEN
SCORES!
PUT IT ON WN TO THE BOTTOM
CORNER.
NO CHANCE
WE WILL WAIT FOR THE OFFICIALS.
GOALTENDER.
HE BEATS
NOW, SVECHNIKOV, GOING WIDE.
ANDREI SVECHNIKOV GOING COAST-
TO-COAST.
A LITTLE SNOW GOT TO THE LOOSE
AND HE KNOCKS IT PAST
KOCHETKOV.  PUCK OFF
THE ICE TO TAKE IT GOES ON NIED
TWO PERIODS, CAROLINA HAS BEEN
OUTSCORING BOSTON 25-3 ACROSS F
THEY WILL CRISSCROSS.
SET DOWN LOW.H THE BLUE
PAINT.
KOTKANIEMI WILL PULL THAT AWAY
BERGERON, WHO SCORES FOR McAVOY.
IT GOES OFF THE HEEL OF HIS
SKATE.
GOOD VISION.
ALSO, A FORTUNATE BOUNCE, AS IT
McAVOY WITH IT.
McAVOY PUTS IT IN,. BINGO!